hello grammarians
now we've already talked about how verbs
can show actions and link concepts and
today i'd like to talk about a third
function of the verb which is helping
other verbs
now we call this the helping verb you
may have heard it called that
or the auxiliary verb
and these are just two words for the
same thing auxiliary is just a more
latin way to say helping that's all it
means now i've brought along an image of
my friend brian
to help explain this principle and what
helping verbs are
is really just inflected forms of the
verbs
to
have and
to be
and as we get deeper into the verb i'll
explain what each one means in each one
of its different versions uh but for now
uh suffice it to say that i'm just going
to throw out some examples just so you
can see what it means for a helping verb
to be a helping verb
so the specific way in which helping
verbs help is that they establish
certain facts about a sentence usually
when they're happening in time and we'll
get more and more into that as we get
more into tenses and
aspect but i just want to give you some
examples so here we have
brian
is
eating
a pizza
ryan and i love pizza we used to eat a
lot of pizza brian
has
eaten
a pizza
brian
was
eating a pizza
and finally
brian
had been
eating
a pizza
so the presence of all these helping
verbs has different effects depending on
which ones you use and as i said we'll
get into those later but
just for a brief overview for example
um
let's see ryan is eating a pizza that
suggests that it's going on now brian
has eaten a pizza that means he had done
it it's over in the past
brian was eating a pizza which means he
was in the middle of eating a pizza when
something happened and finally brian had
been eating a pizza so he was doing it
and then he stopped at some point in
time
and this is just the most basic
introduction to helping verbs so verbs
can show actions verbs can link concepts
verbs can help other verbs
you can learn anything
dave it out